[Music]
you were a babysitter for quite a while
I was I was a baby's had a lot of
families in New York City and it was I
have to say one of the best lessons in
my life I mean even as a person just the
lessons that you learn with kids and the
lessons that you teach you know kids and
honestly even as an artist it's it's
really opened up my artistry because
kids if you ever play with them nothing
is off-limits you know with their
imagination and as an actor that's
really helped me just kind of break open
fearlessness what I found about kids is
that they can be honest sometimes
brutally honest they say things yeah
sometimes that like get like go right
through your chest but then yeah I had
an allotted experience actually like
that had this one just one kid I was
babies it was my first time working with
him and usually when you're in family
home for the first time I always like to
find a place in the house or a toy that
the kid is most comfortable with because
if they're comfortable with it they'll
open up to you so I'm working with this
little kid for the first time and he's
kind of looking at me I want to see what
you say I think he was like seven at the
time there's my memory my memory serves
me he's like seven at the time and he
was kind of looking at me all like who
are you which I expect right and so I
said well what's your favorite toy in
the house and his mom was like show her
show her your plane set and so he went
back to the bedroom and pulled out the
plane set and was like yeah this is the
captain this is the wing and he just
wasn't really into it and so I asked and
I said I have a feeling that you don't
really you're not really into me and he
said well I don't think I'm gonna like
you and I said you don't think you're
gonna like me why not I'm so likeable
and he said he said because you're brown
and it was one of those moments where I
I felt either I could like you know
strangle this kid or you know and just
like god this is a racist family and
just like storm out of the house or if
this is a moment where I could teach and
so I I chose the the higher road and I
said well I asked him I said what's your
favorite sport and he told me kickball
and I said well imagine you were the new
kid in school and everyone was playing
kickball and everyone chose everyone
else on the team and no one chose you
because you were the new kid how would
you feel and he was like bad I guess and
I said okay well that's how I feel that
you're judging me because of my color so
I said do you think you can just take a
moment and get to know me for who I am
and then and then make your judgment off
of me from there and he said all right I
guess and it ended up being one of the
best relationships that I had with her
is that baby said yeah because every
time he saw me he was like Adrian he's
like throw his football or his baseball
hat because he wanted to play baseball
in my house it was just like a moment
where I said I can either I can either
act in anger and hate or teach in love
and so I chose to teach Wow
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's a great it's nice because
obviously that was a great moment for
you but now that's a great moment for a
lot of people that's still very like
today that is that is the what I think
of a lot of people you know didn't react
in anger as much and chose to to speak
and operate in love and I think we'd
we'd get along a lot better yeah thank
you yeah yes yes yes yes yes
you